hallo mein name ist so kaka der am
regelmäßig ssten hochladen
überall die scheuch war wieder auf
twitter gesorgt
ich habe euch auf twitter gesagt freunde
schicken wir mal bescheuerte videos und
da kamen ganz ganz viele bevor wir uns
diesen videos allerdings fehlt mir noch
eine ganz kurze sache und zwar oben
werbevideo einblenden buch cool freut
mich heute ist der dreizehnte zwölfte
das heißt morgen am 14.12 mit ist dieses
buch ja nahezu überall in deutschland in
fast allen buchhandlungen geben und wenn
ihr keine buchhaltung von erhard ist der
entwurf allerdings amazon link also da
könnt jetzt auch bestellt in dem buch
geht es beim einleben also meine mutter
und ich haben über mein ganzes leben
die geschichten rausgesucht zu bildern
um ganz viele private bilder und
formierten anmerkungen drin das ist
nicht so verlaufen ist nur einem arm ist
meinte sondern anders und bla 200 seiten
hey guys definitiv nein ich würde sagen
wir fangen einfach mal mit dem ersten
video wie ich genauso meine damen und
herren also wenn man sich ein produkt
verkauft sei es jetzt die pizza oder
irgendwas aus meinem shop oder sogar das
buch war das morgen rauskommen sollte
man es wirklich einfach kaufen um es
dann in die mülltonne zu schmeißen
mehr gibt es dazu nicht zu sagen also
soll eigentlich jeder machen wtf
der preis für den dümmsten vollidioten
des jahres geht auf jeden fall an dich
herzlichen glückwunsch als belohnung
bekommt sie dafür dass die einen
runtergeholt danke danke dass ihr kind
jetzt frohe weihnachten wünscht dass
warum es bedeutet mir ganz ganz viele
meinem herzen für mich und es stinkt
wenn ich dann immer echt liegt wie wir
miteinander in der community miteinander
umgehen was was rede ich den deutschen
[Musik]
das war schön das ist luca er gehörte
nehme das ist mein buch es gehört in den
müll
katzen sind so komische tiere haben ein
luca ich werde diese ukulele jetzt auch
so verwerfen
nun also muss ich wirklich sagen an der
stelle das ist klasse so gar nicht jeder
kollege auf so verwerfen ist so verdammt
was wasserfläche meisterklasse cola
flaschen cola flasche cola flasche weil
es sich auf jeden fall ein ganz ganz
großes dankeschön an der stelle
dass du mir dann den ganzen flaschen
vorgestellt hast das werde ich jetzt
auch mal hier zeigen wasserflasche das
war's warum schickt bei mir so was
danke auf jeden fall an dich dafür dass
ich gerade 15 sekunden meines lebens
damit beschäftigt habe einem herrlichen
dabei zuzugucken wie es nichts tut
das hat sich definitiv gelohnt guck mal
ein wasser springt
tomaten deiner meinung
damen und herren muss ich ganz ehrlich
mal jetzt wirklich zugeben die geheime
zutat meiner pizza aber nicht
tomatensaft sondern mein buch aber als
kommt morgen ist also hier findet der
beschreibt nacht nach machten acht nacht
nach es ist dunkel als letztes video für
heute hab ich noch mal wieder
vorbereitet ich hatte wirklich sagen
muss das könnte vielleicht ein bisschen
zu bilden für euch sein
das passt doch gar nicht so wie das
format rein weil es wirklich eher in die
kategorie lernvideos rein rutschen würde
glaube ich ich habe trotzdem gedacht ich
zeig euch das video mal also film ab ja
ich weiß auch nicht was das darstellen
sollte das wahr ist von wieder meine
damen und herren ich habe ergeben dass
das mein buch komm morgen raus also ich
könnte keinen wirklichen abchecken in
der buchhandlung oder so meine mutter
nicht ob es ein mega viel mitgegeben da
sind ganz ganz viele private geschichten
von mir drinnen von früher ihr vater ich
würde sagen das ist einmal dein maul
wenn euch das linie gefallen hat das
gerne mal leichter am morgen kommt auf
meinen kanal einen block von den letzten
tagen wo ich unterwegs war wir waren mit
felix ihn am strand ist und wasser
gefallen wir waren mit anderen youtube
unterwegs
das waren waren wir gar nicht einfach
das video
dagegen muss